pues actualmente en el país hay unos 30
focos de llamas de los cuales más de una
veintena siguen activos sin controlar
sobre todo en la mitad oeste del país
aunque hay uno de gravedad que preocupa
bastante al este en cataluña según el
satélite europeo copernicus en lo que
llevamos de 2022 se han quemado ya 87
mil 400 hectáreas el 72% de estas en el
último mes esta cantidad esta superficie
es la misma que se quemó en todo el año
2021 las llamas han dejado como bien lo
decías en los titulares un balance hasta
el momento de dos fallecidos las dos
personas fallecidas han sido hombres en
la provincia de zamora al oeste del país
uno de ellos trabajaba en las labores de
extinción y en la otra persona se cree
que era un pastor el presidente del
gobierno de españa' pedro sánchez y el
rey felipe sexto han visitado algunas de
las zonas afectadas y pedro sánchez ha
recordado la importancia de mantener el
compromiso de la lucha contra el cambio
climático y de mantener las políticas de
mitigación y adaptación
a la crisis energética en la que nos
vemos sumidos tras la guerra en ucrania